I want the I want the then wake up for
fud I prefer to be Walken up by alarms
rather than lemons but did you know
brothers and sisters I wouldn't wake up
for f Salah and I have 1 million
subscribers on YouTube this was because
I wasn't even a Muslim before but the
subscribers came after that but you get
the point I will be sleeping while you
guys are praying but what does the
person who gave me da get now before I
even prayed F when I wake up he gets the
reward when I do wo he gets a reward
when I pray myah he gets the world and
everything in it and then he gets my fud
Salah it's been 11 years since I've been
a Muslim and even today he got the
reward of my fud inah you can do the
same we have helped 10,000 people how to
learn the Salah like like me you can
just give £100 this Ramadan and help
teach 10 to 30 people how to praise
Salah click the button or the link and
help build
today Allah says in the Quran who is it
that will loan Allah a goodly loan so he
may multiply it for him many times over
the prophet Muhammad sallahu alaihi
wasallam said charity does not decrease
wealth so click the button and start
getting the reward
today